[Music]
all right let's go to codeman let's go
to cody in atlanta georgia what's up
cody
hey how are you i'm good hey remember
that time um uh the astros were gonna
get to win the world series and y'all
ruined everything remember that
yeah we finally won something here in
atlanta well i hope that was fun for you
it was not for me so what's up man
hey so um i'm i'm 25 i live in uh
atlanta um and then my girlfriend she's
26 and she lives in new york city
um she just got her master's in acting
actually this week so
her
mfa
yeah mfa very cool where was she at
school in new york
yeah she uh she moved to new york about
three years ago to do that so you all
hung in there long distance for three
years huh
oh no so we she came back during the
summer and um to see your family and
stuff and we met at the coffee shop that
i work at um
and so we did three months together here
in the summer and then we've done the
past eight months um
okay all right so about a year and you
all met at the coffee shop whoa
is that it it's a candy shop that's the
candy shop song not the coffee shop song
the coffee shop song is the boring slow
version
of me at the coffee shop whoa all right
so um y'all been together about a year
and then what
um so originally we planned on me moving
up to new york um around this time
uh because you know i do coffee and i do
live sound so i was like i can get a job
anywhere and she wants to do
um theater and acting and you know a
place to be that's for theater that's
right
and
new york is where dreams are made of
right
yeah absolutely there you go i sound
just like alicia keys on that one i'm
pretty sure okay so i keep interrupting
you go ahead go ahead but you're fine
you're fine um but uh
you know i i recently found um
you know the dave ramsey stuff i started
getting into that and trying to get a
hold of my finances and i just don't see
feasibly how both of us can live in new
york when we're in the entertainment
stuff and just uh it's just costs so
much to live there yeah it's wild man um
and so i mean i told her i was like i
just can't do that and also at the same
time i've been getting a lot of good
opportunities here
uh
in georgia with doing sound which is
what i went to school for so i've been
getting a lot of good opportunities with
letting corporate stuff and just
churches in the area
and there's a lot there's a lot of
entertainment stuff moving to atlanta
it's fast tracking to atlanta which is
just a it's an incredible i remember
back in you know i was in houston most
of my childhood in
all my childhood and i remember when
austin started
blowing up they call it started calling
the third coast right people started
moving it and i feel like atlanta is
there too like there's just some
incredible opportunities there which is
great man good deal absolutely so um
ultimately what's your question
yeah so um she she eventually was um not
eventually that's terrible she also
saw that she couldn't do that so she's
moving back home and um you know we've
just been long distance for so long and
i'm just scared we're not scared like we
have fears but i'm just trying to figure
out what is fears versus what are the
red flags when it comes to our
relationships
hmm
is there have to be a difference
i don't know
um so a red flag for me is something
that violates one of my core values
or um
probably initial red flag is gonna is
gonna violate what i believe to be one
of my beliefs
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to dig in on that red flag and see
if my belief is what i thought it was if
it's if it's a
make or break belief you know what i
mean like me and my wife have voted
differently at times great that's
awesome um we have different opinions on
theology sometimes we have to we have
different opinions on a lot of stuff
especially on music she thinks my
music's awful
um and so
but those are beliefs right and when i
was 25 if you had told me i was married
by then but if i was 24 let's say and i
wasn't married
um i just have a rule if you didn't like
the show seinfeld i just knew we weren't
going to be friends
right so if someone's like i don't i'm
not into that show i just i wouldn't
even continue not trying to be a jerk i
just know where this ends and this ends
with me making a joke that's a little
bit sarcastic can you get your feelings
hurt and we're not gonna be friends
my wife is the first seinfeld uh person
who didn't like seinfeld that i ended up
remaining friends with and then now
we've got a family in a couple of
decades of history so all i have to tell
you is a red flag is something that
initially violates a belief of mine and
ultimately would come down to a
a red light if you will would be a this
violates a value of mine
um
you want to continue to hook up with
other people and that's not somebody
that i want to date right or whatever
what i could come up with a million
different things a fear would just be
uncomfortable right
a fear would be your body telling you
hey this is a risk
is this worth the risk
and
that's that's a that's an equation that
only you can answer really right
okay yeah so so are you are you guys
fighting are you all having
disagreements or where is your is your
is your like your that feeling in your
guts where's that coming from
yeah so um i mean
she said something that i didn't you
know it took me a second to process um
but like she said that she feels like
we'll never move out of georgia because
i'll always have an excuse
to
stay here in georgia okay
and i'm like yeah i mean like
i don't hate it here
you know i've lived here my whole life
and then it just kind of felt like it
was like
she's always going to be upset with me
for not wanting to move if opportunities
come up or i'll find an excuse
and so probably the truth is
yes and yes
is that fair
so only only example i can give you is
from my personal life i come from the
city and i moved out to a west texas
town that was a smaller city
and the moment i landed there i started
plotting my exit
i have to get out of here my body can't
live here i don't want to be here and
then my wife um who's my girlfriend's
time said
this guy will get me out of here like i
don't really think he's that attractive
and he's a humongous head and he puts
too much product in his hair and he
listens to annoying music but he'll get
me out of here right so she hits her
wagon
and
we ended up living in that community for
between 15 to 20 years and it was where
our closest friends are and then there
came a moment when it was time to go and
we knew that and it was it's been great
and she said i just you know she laughed
because i just played the long game
here's what i'm telling you
are we ever going to leave here or i
don't see my future in georgia or i
those are all great valid conversations
those are great and valid disagreements
things to you know
talk on the front end
if somebody looked at me and i've got
friends like this
i will never move away from the town
that my parents live in full stop
that would be a a
i need to i need to examine that can i
live in this community forever because
you're being very clear with me i will
never want to have kids
going into this relationship we're
shaking hands on this are we all on the
same page because so in five years and
you say i really want kids i'm gonna say
i told you as a you know i mean
so um
it sounds to me like
she is falling for you
and
is trying to come up with with reasons
why
um
you don't wanna
she's trying to think 15 years down the
road or five years down the road or ten
years down the road and come up with
with future reasons and project them
into the now and it sounds like you're
doing the same thing
and what i would tell you is
both of you say yes if we have great
opportunities here it's great and if
something cool comes up i'm absolutely
open to hearing that unless you're not
and if you say i will never leave
georgia and i grew up in texas there's
texans it do they they be unemployed
fight in war it doesn't matter i will
never leave texas good for you just make
that clear to the person you're going to
marry does that make sense
absolutely
are you pushing her away
um
no i think
it was just like you know for so long we
talked about being in new york and then
now it's flipped to her now moving
here so i think she just got scared of
me like
it's like all kind of recent
here's what i want you yeah
do i've got a good one
i want you guys to
have a funeral service for the dream of
new york together
and i want y'all to grieve that
it's gonna suck
because y'all had started making plans
about this life and you were going to
run a coffee shop and you were also
going to start running sounds for big
shows and she was going to be on
broadway and it it's not dead trust me
it's not dead it will happen but right
now there's just a dot-dot-dot after it
and it feels like you'll have failed
that you've lost something and you
didn't lose anything other than a dream
and if you don't grieve this thing and
sit on it what th the grief will make
its way into well i told you this and
you never want to do that that's how
it'll end up it'll come out
and you'll end up in fights about things
that are just proxy wars for
i'm really sad that we built this
picture together and it didn't come true
because it's too expensive to live there
if y'all will grieve it and be able to
go
we wanted to do this and it didn't
happen yet
it didn't happen right now
and your wife
your wife your girlfriend was to read a
letter about how sad she was and here's
what she wanted to do about it here's
her dreams and they're not coming true
right now and here's her fears and you
read your dreams and your fears and
you'll read them together and then you
can set that stuff down and then what
you can do is say okay for the next year
let's build a
awesome relationship here in georgia
let's put some let's let's look at how
can we make georgia as awesome as
possible for one year let's just do that
and let's love each other and let's date
and let's get serious and let's have fun
and let's build one year and then we're
going to reevaluate we'll put on the
calendar we'll commit to in one year
we're going to circle back and say how
is this year see what i'm saying and
don't don't have
problems 15 years down the road or 10
years down the road that aren't really
gonna materialize yet okay unless you
know in your soul i will never leave
georgia and if that's the case tell her
that a part of being in relationship and
loving me is never leaving georgia and i
would tell you
don't do that
don't do that
there's a big big world out there man
and love's a really cool thing and um it
will take you to
all corners of the earth right um but
don't
don't get into is this fear this red
flag dude just jump in jump in and say
this hurts what can we build next but
that's a man that is a great great
question cody thank you for asking that
man
um
i don't know for whatever reason maybe
i'm in a good mood today i feel really
good about where you are headed it's
awesome right we all need to be